it was reported today that the Trump
administration will be revoking Obama
era legal guidelines in which the
federal government encourages college to
use race as a factor in admissions as if
they needed encouragement if that's the
case it'll be a long-awaited blow in
favor of equality and civil rights and
standards in American life in more and
more parts of our life in this country
critical decisions are being made simply
on people's appearance on their race or
gender instead of on actual measures of
achievement or merit and that's
terrifying obviously one of the places
where merit is most critical is in
medicine we trust physicians to make a
life-or-death decisions they do every
day competence is critical there
obviously but medical schools don't see
it that way
when applying to medical school two
critical factors are an applicant's GPA
and the score on the medical college
admissions test the MCAT it goes out
saying the prospective doctor ought to
have excellent grades and a high MCAT
score you'd want that for your doctor
but the standards is not the same for
everybody it differs by appearance for
example applicants with an MCAT of 27 to
29 in a GPA of 3.4 to 3.5 9 if you have
those numbers and you're Asian you have
a 21% chance of getting into a medical
school if you're white you have a 29%
chance of getting in with those numbers
but if you're Hispanic you have a 60%
chance of getting in african-american
applicants had an 81 percent acceptance
rate with those numbers in other words
with identical scores an
african-american applicant was four
times as likely to be admitted as an
Asian purely because of appearance
Vijay choked will Ingham knows more than
most people about the dark underbelly of
medical school admissions he is of
Indian heritage but he wanted to go to
medical school so he shaved his head and
started going by his middle name which
is Jojo he presented himself as African
American he says it made all the
difference and got him into medical
school he has written a book on this
experience it's called almost black we
spoke to him recently here's part of the
conversation did you thank you very much
for joining us tonight
so if you are convinced based on your
experience that your race or what the
medical school perceived your race to be
was critical in getting in so exactly
like you mentioned I reviewed the
statistical data published by the
American Association Medical Colleges I
figured out that I was much more likely
to get into admission as in an
african-american there's an Asian
American so I came up with that scam
that you described earlier I managed to
get into Washington University and I'm
sorry get wait-listed at Washington
University and the University of
Pennsylvania which are the third and
fourth the best medical schools in the
country at the time and I managed to get
into st. Louis University School of
Medicine despite the fact that my 3.1
GPA was dramatically lower than their
average of three-point-seven so my plan
paid off much more than I expected what
does it say about the people who run
medical schools that they've been
willing to lower standards for
physicians many of whom you know wield
scalpels for a living cut people open in
the name of some abstract diversity goal
that seems reckless so as a result of
this system they essentially allow
students who are not as qualified as
others to get in now I don't want to
talk about the end product whether this
results in physicians who are of lower
quality but I will say that it is a
system of legalized racism the
universities are promoting and medical
schools are promoting discrimination
against asian-americans on a massive
scale and it also promotes negative
stereotypes about the competency and
professionalism of African American
physicians and that's right health care
professionals you know it's important to
realize that there was a University of
Illinois urbana-champaign shuddhi which
showed that affirmative action actually
promoted negative stereotypes about
African Americans in his band
students so that is there some reason oh
of course it is is there some reason
that we should care about what our
doctors look like is appearance critical
to practicing medicine so first of all I
never graduated medical school so I
can't say that is but ultimately we want
to live in a society where you judge
someone based on merit your race should
not be relevant to your ability to
practice medicine or anything
effectively that's not the type of
society in which we want to promote
necessarily yes well I'm sure you've
taken criticism for this I think you're
a hero for doing it and I would love to
hear your critics explain exactly what
you did wrong because they can thank you
for joining us appreciate it